there was a sort of meeting of the minds
on television a few days ago I don't
know how the universe was able to
tolerate the joining of purveyors of
such big ideas with big brains but
Donald Trump's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani showed up on none other than
Fox & Friends and the video is simply
stunning Rudy Giuliani was so unhinged
in this video in the middle of the
impeachment trial of Donald Trump that
the Fox and Friends people kept trying
to end the interview and interrupt Rudy
but Rudy would not allow it it became an
embarrassment for everybody involved
Rudy the day before the interview said
he had all this compelling evidence to
provide that the real story here is Joe
Biden tried to pull the Obama
administration and Hillary into
something or other George Soros all this
crazy stuff everything other than Trump
extorted you to Ukraine to smear Biden
let's start just with some of Rudy
beginning not to make sense you'll see
the totally biased audience is still
clapping right now eventually they're
gonna completely glaze over you'll see
the looks on the faces of the hosts
starting to realize that Rudy Giuliani
may not be playing with a full deck
check out the shots of the crowd as well
if you're watching this is just the
beginning I'm gonna present over the
next two to three weeks shocking crimes
at the highest levels of both
governments while the Senate is
listening to a totally phony group of
stories about non impeachable offenses
it's like trying somebody for not a
crime it's a total waste of money it's a
complete show on the part of the
Democrats right and they should be sued
for conspiracy to defraud the United
States and they should pay for that
hearing but but mr. mayor
to pay to that television advertiser and
you talk about interfering in the 2020
election you know I started
investigating Biden two years ago when
he was thinking about running for
president I never thought he would run
so Rudy keeps getting more and more
conspiratorial and things start to get
really weird and even Rudy starts to
lose his train of thought in the middle
of these weird things that he's saying
and the hosts are starting to get
uncomfortable and shifting in their
seats and realizing that Rudy's making
no sense and we've got to be polite
because it's Trump's lawyer but this is
really going sideways in the middle of
the corruption presentation one
gentleman said to me well you know about
the the Biden bribe I said were you
talking about
he said well Biden but I didn't got paid
off and and he went to poroshenko he
forced a prosecutor out not only did he
get his son out but he got barrese mouth
so one of the things we're gonna reveal
we always think well you always asked
why did this happen why would a crooked
Ukrainian oligarch whose company is
about to be taken away from who's
sitting in Switzerland with five billion
dollars he stole oh this is just fact
his name is my Cola
and slow chefs key this is all true what
I just said he hires the son of the vice
president who just got thrown out of the
Navy for failing a drug test had been in
and out of rehab most of his life so
this continues for a while and I won't
play it all but eventually the hosts
start to more successfully interrupt
here's another portion of it and then
you'll see the hosts get involved none
of it is making sense you'll see Brian
Kilmeade try to stop Rudy
but you can't stop Rudy you can only
hope to contain him and then right after
that is when Biden says get rid of
Shogun and Shogun will test token will
testify to that and I will show you a
document that in September of last year
Shogun was taken to the hospital with
mercury poisoning all right so let me
just get a word in I know you
Rapids you know this happens in Ukraine
and Russia right a choice is poisonous
so let's just say that everything you
say proves 100 percentage it is 100
percent you also say would you also say
that the way you approached it for in
the short term which were in the middle
of has made things worse for the mother
I would say the way I approach it is for
the benefit of the American people
notice the audience is completely out by
now they don't even know what Rudy's
talking about at first they sort of
understood Rudy was saying things that
sounded good to them and they were
clapping and cheering and they would cut
to the audience the audience has gone
completely silent now because they have
no clue what Rudy's talking about here
Steve Doocy tries to jump in Rudy just
won't let him and Rudy then loses his
train of thought again Steve Doocy tries
to interrupt two more times
Brian Kilmeade tries deucey tries again
and they just can't and even Ainsley
Earhardt
is trying to interrupt he is not
prosecuted he is sitting there fat and
happy with his company and then we got
another bribe you don't think the
President of the Ukraine shared in that
five billion dollars at the crook cap
Rudy the bribe to the President of the
Ukraine the amount of money I can't be
absolutely sure let's say let's say it's
well in excess of ten million dollars
you know the entire crowd and that
shouldn't be revealed from a lawyer who
finds out about this to you am I gonna
cover it up the way the Democrats and
the media cover it up it's absolutely
not i prosecute a too many corruption
cases to sit by and watch my country
sold out by a vice-president who did it
two other times at least in China so how
does this end can you imagine no one has
any idea what Rudy is talking about they
have no clue
here's Ducey again just relentlessly
trying to put an end to this insanity
they're coming after me Rudy we want to
kill me are you when are you going to
present the reputation the interruption
Shokan they're trying to really kill
Ernie when are you going to present the
evidence because you tell a compelling
story why today today at noon so here it
starts to seem like it's going a little
bit better and Rudy is kind of calming
down but then it turns back around and
Giuliani's talking about George
Soros and then the hosts really don't
know what hit them they start to look
dazed you can kind of jump back into
this anywhere and it would make no sense
no matter where you started the video
but let's look at another segment that's
when they move the ambassador and they
never bothered to investigate the
allegations that she interfered in for
investigations that she was campaigning
for Hillary Clinton during the 2016
election the Ambassador the Ambassador
that one of the cases she had dropped
was on George Soros his company intact I
didn't hear any of this yesterday
antek an tact with gathering dirty
information on Trump so this is about
the chef's key and poroshenko and hunter
Biden and Joe Biden and Obama and
Hillary and George Soros but definitely
none of this is actually about Donald
Trump the next moment is one of my
favorites Rudi's cadence starts to
suggest he's winding down and you can
see Steve Doocy spots the window of
opportunity opening where he might be
able to take control back of this
nonsense
but then Rudy just gets going again and
the hosts all looked dejected you think
it's just Biden who was cashing in in
the Ukraine and then every time you hear
the word Biden was Obama's point man
there's something that follows the Biden
family makes millions of dollars they
made they got an investment in a 1.5
billion dollar housing program in Iraq
when Biden was named employment I've
been on the wrong end of interviews like
this before where you simply cannot get
the guest under control this is 13
minutes in total Rudy is going on about
everything from there are two bribes
well actually no there are three bribes
so this is about George Soros so this is
about Iraq and the hosts can't get it
under control and the audience has been
gone after minute number two notice the
first two minutes the audience was
cheering the propaganda they have no
clue what's going on they've stopped
listening it's dead silent in there and
then here's the last series of attempts
and Steve Doocy has to half jokingly say
you have to stop talking now by saying
I'm sure you could go until noon Rudy
and Ainsley Earhardt laughs like it's
all fun and games but the three of them
look like they're I don't know how
any of you have seen the movie airplane
from 1984 hilarious movie there's a
scene in airplane where the main
character Ted striker is sitting on an
airplane and he starts telling these
endless stories to the woman traveling
next to him and every time they cut to
the woman she looks sicker and sicker to
her stomach and ultimately she actually
hangs herself in the movie it's a joke
and Ted striker is just continuing to
tell the story the hosts look like that
woman and Rudy will not stop here Dulce
finally manages to end it and say what
are you kid yes sir your son's got a
no-show job for millions of dollars
you're in the pocket of slow chefs ki
and you're telling us not to be curved
do you know how that hurt you could go
clear till noon when your podcast starts
give it up for Rudy
that's the real case probably the tip of
the iceberg there are other people
involved there's a lot more money
involved there was a pattern of Josh in
that and even in ending it Steve Doocy
still can't stop Rudy Guiliani from
getting a little bit more in there that
podcast Rudy is hosting where he's gonna
give you all of this evidence that
podcast really sounds like a fun listen
right does anybody agree with me Fox
News desperate to control Rudy trying
and failing for 13 minutes this should
actually be Exhibit A for journalism
classes in how not to allow the guests
to take control of the interview and
unfortunately this happens to everyone
we've had people on this show where I
lose control of the guest and we've had
situations where it ends up going 40
minutes and we end up just having to
remove an entire part of it and say
we'll put that online and only using a
fraction of it for the broadcast show
because of time constraints it's
happened to me you almost start to feel
bad for the three hosts of Fox News
because it's happening to them until you
remember that they are the host of Fox &
Friends and active participants in being
purveyors of endless dangerous pro-trump
propaganda then I don't feel quite so
bad for them but an incredible unhinged
off the rails appearance by Rudy
Giuliani quick break we'll be back after
this